[Music]
michael's in salem oregon hi michael
welcome to the show how can we help
hi dave how are you doing better than i
deserve man what's up
awesome um so i work for a fallen sun
company me being the sun in it
um and i was kind of wondering do you
have any tips or advice on hiring our
first employee
um and i was also going to ask is it nda
or non-complete
viable is that is that a good option or
what do you do
um we're a graphic design and vehicle
wrap kind of company so we do anything
advertising for our clients
apparel et cetera
okay well getting into your business is
tough so i don't know why someone would
be a big threat to leave you and be in a
comp competitive situation and really
they wouldn't take anything with them
except just their two hands
yeah the the problem is a lot of times
um we've kind of had have it happened to
us in the past and get burnt
um
they're gonna take the knowledge and you
know like the resources of where we get
our supplies um our kind of pricing
behind the scenes etc
um and then it just creates and breeds
competition if you're not really smart
about it well yeah you can you can have
you could have a simple two-page
contract or something drawn up that just
says there's proprietary
processes and vendor contacts
and customer contacts that you can't
take with you
um and if you do we will shut you down
that you're invited that's not even a
non-compete that's just there's
proprietary things we do that here in a
very general sense we're not not as
strict as what you're talking about but
there's some just basic interest i mean
you can't steal a customer list that's
illegal i mean even without a contract
you can enforce that in any state as an
example
and i've had that happen a couple of
times and i just have to call them up
and go you know you can't do that and
and then they don't sometimes people are
just dumb and they don't realize it but
um
uh
you know that that's the thing the other
thing is you fix a lot of this on the
higher when you're hiring
and john you know talk let's talk about
screening
in the hiring process i think that makes
a big difference yeah that's a huge
difference is you get to know the person
that you're hiring you know their
character to know what their skill set
is
i i go back to that old zig ziglar quote
the only thing worse than
training somebody having them leave is
not training them and having them stay
and so i want to find somebody that i
can trust and really train well
and give them all the insights there and
then you and your family are gonna have
to really be intentional about the
dynamic between you and your dad and
bringing in a third
like a a new person right who's not a
family member that's gonna be a whole
different ball of wax
but yeah you've got to have somebody
that you trust that you put through the
ringer and skills and character and what
they think about things do you like
being around them that's a big thing
like are we going to get along here
it just changes the dynamic of your
business yeah it's a small business by
definition so there's a lot you're going
to be in the proximity with them all the
time and
there's nothing
illegal or wrong with saying
i don't want to hang out with this
person all day
i mean they may be good at their job but
you know but in our in our culture today
we've
uh
deteriorated in the hiring process to
think if we just hire someone to do the
job that that's the only responsibility
we have and it's just the very minimum
right you got to do a whole lot more
than that around here we call it are
they a culture fit
and it we we don't lose people very
often for not being able to do their job
but we do lose some folks that aren't
culture fits
meaning they don't want to be around us
we don't be around them and so one of us
makes the decision in that process and
go bye-bye and so and and so yeah you do
all that you love them well the thing i
would tell you to do in order to get the
right people in the building is the
number one mistake people make as they
first start adding
to their team is they don't take enough
time
i want you to interview them a minimum
of four times
preferably six
and that sounds laborious it sounds over
the top but i tell you what about that
fifth interview sitting on the back
porch somewhere with a cup of coffee
they'll say something you go
not doing that
and you know because people can dress up
and say stuff for about two or three
interviews that anything that make you
happy but you just keep hanging out with
them a little bit eventually if there's
something crazy going on they'll reveal
they're crazy and you'll reveal yours
and let's be real clear about that you
and your dad have a special kind of
weird that y'all how y'all interact what
y'all think's funny what you think
someone's going to have to want to spend
time with you all so i think that those
interviews go both ways right
you know i never thought of that because
i just thought everybody wanted to be
around me
except it's the narcissism thing you go
there it is yeah
but no you're right i mean it's not
ramsay's not for everybody it's not and
that's okay i'm still i'm i'm really
okay with it yeah unbelievably okay with
it
i there's a lot of jobs that we could do
uh like you know you do the ski i have a
skill set for but
we're not gonna like hanging out with
each other every single day eight hours
ten hours working late nights figuring
it finishing projects together and
that's okay that's part of the it's part
of the fit conversation i think you and
your dad need to sit down and have a
conversation about what are we looking
for what's what skill set do we need
what kind of what ways can we train this
person over time what responsibilities
they want to take from us and you and i
we may yell at each other we may
cold shoulder each other let's be honest
about that when we bring somebody in
yeah but the work environment yeah and
when i came here y'all are honest about
the work environment this is how we
talked about what it is like here yeah
yeah very a lot we talk about a lot
because we want you to self select out
if you think we're weird and we are kind
of weird and there's enough meetings
that i got to see some of it live right
i have to see some of the disagreements
or this and i think that and i got to
see it how it happens and i think those
are healthy yeah it's a you know how to
have a good argument
uh
and and so last thing is this
if you're going to grow your business
and you're going to add your head to
your team
two things are going to happen
over time
one is it's going to be the most
rewarding
part of running a business is having
high quality people in your life walking
alongside you
causing your dream to happen and it
becomes their dream
and it's soul enriching and it's awesome
the second thing is going to happen is
some people are going to betray you
they're going to lie about you
they're going to cheat and they're going
to break your heart and you better get
ready for both and you better enjoy the
ride baby because both are gonna happen
if you hire more than one person
if you hire one person you're gonna get
one or the other but we don't know which
but you just keep it up i mean i got
some of my best friends on the planet
some of the highest quality human beings
i know work on this team yeah and
some of the biggest jerks on the planet
that
man oh man i could just go off on
used to work here
and
oh man
and it just breaks your heart and some
of them i'm not angry with but just make
you kind of want to throw up a little
bit you know that i put money into that
and i poured my life into that and it's
just uh that's part of what it is and
but hey it's the joy of doing you know
your other options stay home do nothing
no thank you right
let's bring it man game on yeah it's uh
it is it's enriching it's kind of like
you know
i guess the rest of things in life you
just embrace the good and and there's
always there's never a hundred percent
pure no awesomeness with anything no you
need that that pain side to balance out
the pleasure side of the teeter totter
there how well you know what it is
when you hired your first employee here
at a
what is a really a large family business
was that strange was that weird
very weird very weird but he stayed 20
years yeah so they're pretty good on the
first yeah the second one stayed
45 days
[Laughter]
swing and a miss yep yep yep i was so
good at it i thought i could do it again
of course
and the third one stayed
that took her place
two years or three years yeah now which
is pretty good and we're still friends
yeah wonderful and by the way i'm
friends with all three of those yeah but
i can imagine the first hire when you
have a family business it's it feel it
would feel really personal because
you're taking my name you're taking the
thing that i've built from nothing i
don't know it feels like you'd feel more
personal to me yeah i guess but i i
think if you own the business
well it makes a family business i guess
yeah instantly yeah it's just i mean
ours has got our name on it like in the
spotlight and stuff so that's even
weirder yeah yeah but if you he owns a
sign company or a graphics company for
putting wraps on cars and stuff but it's
his baby he's got his name on it and
them screwing up
mess up his personal reputation at
church yeah yeah you know that stuff
that's real that's very great so just
know it's going to be weird yeah you
know it's going to be weird that's part
of the joy of the whole process yeah
have fun with it